صعدت القوى السياسيه والنقابيه والمدنيه
المناهضه للرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
احتجاجاتها ضد المسار السياسي الذي يقوده
الرئيس بمناسبه ذكرى الثانيه عشره للثوره
التونسيه وبينما طالبت القوى السياسيه
المعارضه برحيل سعيد دعى الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل الى مسماه خيارا ثالثا لاخراج
البلاد من ازمتها السياسيه والاقتصاديه
الراهنه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاث مسارات ما الاسباب التي اوصلت
المشهد التونسي الى مرحله التازيم السياسي
والاقتصاديه الراهنه مع حلول الذكرى
الثانيه عشره للثوره التونسيه كيف سيتعامل
الرئيس التونسي مع تصاعد الاحتجاجات
الرافضه لمساره السياسي وما الاوراق التي
تملكها القوى المعارضه له بالضغط عليها
وما المقالات المحتمله من سداد الافق
السياسي في تونس وما فرص الحوار بين اطراف
العمليه السياسيه من سلطه واحزاب ونقابات
[موسيقى]
شاهدت العاصمه التونسيه يوم السبت مظاهرات
نحاسده احتجاجا على المسار السياسي للرئيس
قيس سعيد واحياء لذكرى الثانيه عشره
للثوره التونسيه وقد طالبت المظاهرات التي
شاركت فيها ايضا قوى مدنيه ونقابيه برحيل
الرئيس ونددت بمسمته تفرده بالسلطه
وتهديده الحقوق والحريات وانتهاكه
لاستقلال القضاء بحسب وصفها كما شهدت
المظاهرات التي شاركت فيها منفرده كل من
جبهه الخلاص وتنسيقيه الاحزاب الديمقراطيه
الاجتماعيه والحزب الدستوري الحر شهدت
دعوات الى تعبئه العامه من اجل اسقاط
الرئيس قيس سعيد الذي حمله المتظاهرون
مسؤوليه الازمه الاقتصاديه
والمعيشيه الحاده في تونس
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الذي لم
يشارك في مظاهرات السبت دعا منه العام نور
الدين الطبوبي الى الاستعداد لم سماها
معركه وطنيه من اجل انقاذ تونس واعلن
اعتزامه تنفيذ تحركات نقابيه قطعيه ذات
مطالب اجتماعيه كما اكد الاتحاد تمسكه
بالحريات ومناهضته اي محاوله لقمعها
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من تونس
عبد اللطيف المكي القيادي في جبهه الخلاصه
الوطنيه
اهلا بك شكرا على الاستضافه راينا خمس
مجموعات تقريبا تتظاهر رئيس الجمهوريه
وداخل كل مجموعه من هذه المجموعه
ولكن حال التصدي والتشرد كبيره في المشهد
السياسي في تونس خاصه في هذه المعارضات
هناك جبهه الخلاصه التي هي عماد وحركه
النهضه مع بعض الوجوه الاخرى
التي كما لم يقوله مالك الخمره والعكس
بالعكس جواهر بن مبارك ورضا بالحاج ونجيب
الشاب الذين لو عدنا الى مواقفهم منذ مده
رايناهم يقولون في لكن ما كانوا يقولونه
ولا نفس الشيء بالنسبه
لمحمد بغض النظر عما يقوله اطيافه
المعارضه بحق بعضهم البعض وبغض النظر عن
خلافاتهم اليوم هناك مشهد همم في الشارع
التونسي معارضه تطالب برحيل الرئيس تحمله
مسؤوليه تردي الاوضاع الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه في البلاد وتقول انه هو يتحمل
المسؤوليه ذلك وهناك سلطه ايضا تحاول ان
تقطع الطريق امام هذه التظاهرات كيف وصلت
الامور الى هذه النقطه باعتقادك
هناك تباين في مواقف هذه المعارضات جابتها
خلاص تحمل قيس سعيد المسؤوليه مثلا
والاحزاب الخمسه وتحمل حركه النهضه وقيس
سعيد المسؤوليه وهو نفس موقف الحزب
الدستوري الحر اذا ليس لا يمكن حديث عن
معارضه موحدا هناك ازمه سياسيه لا تبدو
هناك اي بوادر للحل هناك فشل الاقتصادي
واجتماعي من من الحكومه تجربه وهو فشل
اقتصادي ومجتماعي تعود يعود الى ثلاث
اسباب العشريه الفارقه التي كانت ثقيله
على التونسي الازمه الاوكرانيا الروسيه
ومخلفات الحكومه قد مع بعض الميلسات خاصه
فتحا الملفات القضائيه الكبرى للفاسدين
والمهربين وتوفير المواد الاساسيه وهناك
معارضه مشطه تقريبا
في الشارع للمره تقريبا على الاقل 70 او
80 مره دون ان دون ان يقعوا غير شيء عموما
ما يقع في تونس مسار ديمقراطي همم من
يريدون ان يحتاجونه
نحتاج سابقا في عهد حركه النهضه وحتى في
عالم البلاليه
يتواصل المشهد هكذا في ظل سياسي كبير لا
يبشر بتغيير اي شيء في العاشر عبد اللطيف
مكي ما رايك
اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بك وابي ضيفك استاذه
المشاهدين
مظاهره اليوم
ابلغت دروس كبيره وكثيره ابتداء من ان كل
القوى السياسيه للشعب التونسي اصبحت موحد
على مستوى الموقف من انقلاب قيس سعيد وكل
وقت طالبه بالرحيل وبالاستقاله
وتطالب بحوار وطني لايجاد حل الازمه
التونسي هذه هي الرساله الاولى الرساله
الثانيه ان الدوله اصبحت تضج اجهزه الدوله
اصبحت تضجه
ومتقلقه من قرارات السلطه السياسيه لقيس
سعيد
فقرار السلطه السياسيه بمنع مظاهره جبهه
الخلاص
حمل الاجهزه الامنيه همم مسؤوليه هي ليست
لها وراين كيف ان ما هي انفرضت هذا
التظاهر والدرس الثالث وان قيس سعيد اراد
ان يمحو هذه الذكرى من التاريخ التونسي
ولكن الشعب ثبتها وبالتالي اليوم
المظاهرات ثبتت ميزان قوه جديد لصالح
الحركه الديمقراطيه وضد قيس سعيد الذي همم
تجرد من اي شرعيات دستوريه وشعبيه وسياسيه
ولم يبقى له الا الصراخ
عندما خرج سيد عبد اللطيف السيد محمد همم
وصف لك همم الانقسامات في داخل المعارضه
التونسيه قال ان من خرج اليوم الى الشارع
معارضه ولكنها ليست موحده ما يجمعها هو
الانقسام همم
تحديدا الانقسام بين اجابات الخلاص
وتنسيقيه الاحزاب كيف ترد على هذه المساله
يمكن ان تكون المعارضه متنوعه ومنقسمه حول
قضايا اخرى لكن اليوم موحده في مواجهه
انقلاب قيس سعيد وهذه هي الحقيقه التي
يريد ان يهرب منها قيس سعيد حتى الذين
ساندوه في بدايه الانقلاب الان تخلوا عنه
بدرجات مختلفه ولذلك بالنسبه لقضيه انقلاب
قيس عيد المعارضه موحده في هذا الاتجاه
واصبحت ترى فيه يعني همم ازمه لتونس ولا
يمثلوا اي حل ولا يمكن يملك امكانيات اي
حل فنحن نقيس الوحده بالقضيه المطروحه
اليوم والتي هي قضيه مواجهه الانقلاب
واستعاده الديمقراطيه في هذا المعارضه
الموحده سواء كانت في تنظيم واحد او في
خمسه او في 10 همم تنظيمات والشعب اثبت
ذلك اليوم
هل تقول لنا سيد عبد اللطيف المكي ان كل
الاحزاب المعارضه والاطياف المعارضه التي
نزلت اليوم الى الشارع موافقه على ما طرحه
رئيس جبهه الخلاص بضروره ايجاد رئيس بديل
للبلاد شخصيه توافقيه يلتف حولها الجميع
كذلك الحزب الجمهوري جبهه الخلاص كل
الاحزان يائست من قيس سعيد لانه لا يريد
الحوار الاحباب
الاجتماعيه هل هي موافقه على هذا الطرح
تط
الب نعم هي تطالب برئيس برحيل قيس سعيد
لان كل هنالك كل الاحزاب بما في ذلك جبهه
الخلاص عند بدايه الانقلاب
وعندما ظهرت الاحزاب المكونه الان اا لزمه
الخلاص والاحذيه الاخرى
طالما قيس سعيد باداره حوار ولكنه يعرفها
لكنها رفضوا وكل قراراته التي تضرب
الحريات والمراسيم واليوم عشرات المحاكمات
حتى الذين كانوا يطالبون به اداره همم
الحوار الان اصبح
بالرحيل لانه ان يقبل قيس عايد به اداره
حوار هذه مثلا اصبحت مستحيله والسيد قيس
عايده اصبح يقود سياسه الهروب الى الامام
وباساليب شبه انتحاريتهم والبلاد ولدهم
واوضاع البلاد
المكي بالقول ان كل اطياف المعارضه التي
نزلت اليوم الى الشارع موحده حول فكره
ضروره رحيل الرئيس قيس سعيد
هناك اختلاف كبير في المعارضه جامعه
الخلاصه التي عماد وحركه النهضه تطالب قيس
سعيد بالرحيل
وتتبرا من اي مسؤوليه
العسكريه السوداء
الجبهه الاخرى التي فيها 5 احزاب تحمل
حركه النهضه المسؤوليه وهي لا تريد
التفاوض ابدا مع حركه النهضه حتى ان
التيار الديمقراطي اقوى هذه الاحزاب قد
خيل الرجلان الاول والثاني فيها السيد حسن
وهو يقول لك يعني المعارضه طبعا في داخلها
اختلافات ولكن الان الجامع المشترك هو
توافق الجميع على ضروره رحيل الرئيس قيس
سعيد
ولكن لا تختلف على طريقه ترحيل قيس سعيد
ولا على طريقه الحوار ولن ولن تتوحد لان
لو عدنا الى مواقف حزب العمال مثلا يحمل
حركه النهار سياسيه التيار
الحزب الدستوري الحر على كامل
على بقاء هذه الاختلافات في داخل المعارضه
يعني طالما هناك اختلافات في داخل
المعارضه لا يتم التعاطي معها هل هذا هو
الامر هل هكذا يتم التعاطي مع الازمه
الان ازمه هناك ازمه سياسيه في تونس
اسبابها وهي ثلاث اسباب الرئيسيه هناك
ازمه سياسيه ايضا في تونس الان حتى الشارع
التونسي لم يعد يطيع اي احد
خلال عشر سنوات الفارقه في هذه مثل هذه
الاشهر شهر ايجابي وباسمبر كان الحركه
السياسي كان الحراره متواجد في سيدي بوزيد
وفي الحوض
وفي الاحياء الشعبيه وذلك من تونس العاصمه
هذه السنه ليس هناك اي حراك سياسي
التونسيون سائلوا السياسا ابتعدوا على
الانتخابات وابتعدوا عن الشارع وتركوا هذه
النقب بين قوسين ترجع لوحدها بطبعها
المستفيد الاكبر هو قيس سعيد الذي لو اراد
ان يقوم ببعض التغيرات مثلا فتح بعض
الملفات الكبرى المحاسبه او انجاز بعض
فجاه او على الاقل في الاتجاه في اتجاه
اصلاح المنظومه الجبائيه او توفير المواد
الاساسيه والتخفيض فيها لا استعاد شعبياته
اذا مجبر العمليه السياسيه
الان يمكن قيس سعيد ان يصلحه ولكن لا يمكن
لهذه المعامله في ظل التشتتها في ظل
انقسام ان تقدم اي شيء في المشهد السياسي
في تونس
في البلاد يتحمل المسؤوليه العشريه
الماضيه من حكم في خلال السنوات الماضيه
منذ الثوره يتحمل مسؤوليته الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه بحسب ما قال لنا السيد محمد
زويد لماذا المعارضه تريد تحميل كل وزر كل
شيء للرئيس سعيد وهو يعني ربما مسؤول عن
همم الامور بشكل كامل منذ سنه ونصف فقط
السيد قائد سعيد مسؤول على الحكم منذ سنه
2019 بتاريخ انتخابه وهو الذي عين الحكومه
الاولى
السيد المشيشي وهو شريك في الحكم ولم نرى
منه الا التعطيل ولم نرى منه الا
الاستعداد للانقضاض على الحكم والانقلاب
ولكننا لما كنا نصدق توجه ساتنا حتى
رايناه يحدث انقلابا ولذلك هو شريك في
المسؤوليه
وعندما قام بالانقلاب عبر اجهزه الدوله
والان يفكك منظومه القضاء والان هو يحمل
الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه مسؤوليه فشل
السياسي من خلال محاوله توجيهها هي
والقضاء الى مواجهه المعارضه ولذلك لم تعد
المعارضه فقدت تطالب برحيل قيس سعيد بل
اصبحنا لدينا انتباع بان الاجهزه نفسها
اصبحت من هذا السلوك والاجتماع الاخير
الذي قام به السيد قيس سعيد لاحظوا كل
التونسيون ولذلك نحن لا نقول ان العشريه
الماضيه كانت كلها نجحات كانت عشريه
بالالوان كنا نحاول من خلال خدمه الشعب
التونسي ولكن كانت هنالك قوى
مضاده تحاول العرقله استطعنا ان نواجه
الارهاب باقتدار واستطعنا ان نحافظ على
الحريه واستطعنا ان نحافظ على تزويد السوق
واستطعنا ان نطور من البنيه التحتيه والى
غير ذلك لكن كانت هنالك صعوبات كبيره
والسيد قيس عايد منذ انتخابه يمارس الا
التعطيل ولذلك اليوم الشعب التونسي واعي
بان قيس سعيد هو حجره عذراء امام حل
المشكله الاقتصادي والاجتماعي ولذلك الشعب
التونسي قاطع الانتخابات مقاطعه صارخه في
الدوره الاولى لم يشارك الا العداد القليل
المركز كارتير يقول ان المشاركه لم تتجاوز
5%
واعتقد بحسب انطباعي ان المشاركه كانت اقل
من 5% الا يستوعب هذه الرساله لا يستوعب
رساله اليوم ولذلك هم يمارسون سياسه
الهروب الى الامام نحن مستعده موضوع عن
الرسائل همم لو بقينا في هذا الموضوع
الرئيس التونسي الرئيس سعيد كان قد استبق
تظاهرات السبت بتاكيده ان البلاد في حاله
حرب مع الفساد ومع من وصفهم بالخونه
والعملاء
عباره لا بد ان ينطلق نحن في حاله التحرك
ضد الفساد
في استرجاع امل الاموال المنهومه من الشعب
وبسترجع خاصه ببعض العائدات من هذه الى
الشركات الاهليه
اعود الى السيد محمد الذويب سيد محمد هل
يستطيع الرئيس التونسي الاستمرار بهذا
الخطاب خطاب التخوين الحديث عن خونه
وعملاء وانه يواجه هؤلاء في كل مره تخرج
المعارضه لتعارض الاوضاع في البلاد تعارض
ما يقوم به
هو خطاب التخوين وهذا خطاب الذي لا يلتقي
الى مشهد سياسي في دوله من المفروض انها
شاهدت ثوره بين معاقين منذ عشر سنوات لا
يرتقي من الجانبين بطبيعه الحال المعارضه
خطابها لم يرتقي ولا ايضا رئيس الجمهوريه
خطابه يراوح مكانه في الخونه في العملاء
وما الى ذلك بطبيعه الحال كلنا نتمنى من
الجانبين ان يكون الخطاب اكثر راينا ايضا
اجابه خلاص اليوم وغير الاحزاب ترفع الى
فتيات بالانجليزيه والفرنسيه وليس حتى
الذين يرفعون هذه الشعارات يفهمون معناها
محمد المعارضه كانت بدات بالمطالبه بحوار
مع الرئيس وكل همم يعني طلبت به كان يقابل
بالرصد من قبل الرئيس حتى وصل الامر الى
المطالبه مطالته بالتنحي
لهذه المعارضه ان ترفع الشعارات التي تريد
ولا رئيس الجمهوريه ان يقول ما يريد ولكن
ايضا هذه المعارضه وصلت الى رئيس
الجمهوريه بعد ان دعاره ضمان المصبودي
الامريكان الى قطع الدوائر التونسيين وبعد
ان دعاها مرشد الغنمشي الى التدخل وبعد ان
ذهب مها المضيوم عشرات المرات اليكم رسوما
الى ذلك من استدعاء الخارج بطبيعه الحال
كلنا نتمنى الا يحدث كل هذا اذا من حق
رئيس الجمهوريه ان يصف هؤلاء الاشخاص يقول
اشخاص السياسيه بالعملاء طالما انهم
يستجدون خارج في تونس هناك ازمه خطاب في
تونس من الجانبين خطاب رئيس الجمهوريه لم
يرتقي الى مستواه ما يمكن ان تشهده بلال
بعد ثوره بعد عشر سنوات ولكن ايضا خطاب
خطاب هذه الاحزاب الاخرى بقي يا راديا في
تونس هناك ازمه نخب رئيس الجمهوريه فاشله
ولكن هذه المعارضات فشلت
اغلى مسؤوليه
التي تعرض اي الصعيد اليوم من حركه ومن
همم ومن الطياره الديره في الكرامه هي
دعمت قيس سعيد خلال الدوره خلال الدوره
الثانيه للانتخابات
واضحت فكره سيد محمد سيد عبد اللطيف المكي
الان من المسؤول عن التقريب بين مختلف
الاطراف من المسؤول عن توحيد القوى في
البلاد
على التقارب مع بعضهم ببعض
ونحن دائما باتصال مع مختلف في القوى
السياسيه
وتونسيون القوه السياسيه خاصه يستوعب عبر
التاريخ بان اختلافاتها وصراعتها لحد ما
كانت قيس سعيد من ان يستغلها ويبرر بها
هذا الانقلاب ولذلك اليوم برنامج قيس سعيد
هو القضاء على الحريات وتنصيب برلمان شكلي
ومحاكمه المناضلين السياسيين وهو لم يحاسب
الفاسدين بل يحاسب المدونين في الفيسبوك
ويحاسب المناضلين السياسيين الذين
يعاردونه اصبح حجر امام همم التقدم تونس
ورئاسه الغنوشه او ماهر المعيوب او اي
نائب اخر لم يطلب تدخل القوه الخارجيه
وانما قاموا بدورهم كمسؤولين رسميين كانوا
واقف في البرلمان
بالقضيه التونسيه لدى الاطراف الدوليه
اللي هي مرتبطه بتونس باتفاقيات قيس سعيد
وهو المستفيد من التدخلات الخارجيه وانا
قلت ان وصول قيس سعيد لرئاسه الجمهوريه هو
كمين سياسي محكم نصب لتونس ووقعت فيه ويجب
ويجراء تحقيق امن قومي حول هذه المساله
بالذات بالذلك اليوم مشكله تونس الاساسيه
هي الانقلاب الذي يجب ان يزول انت تقول ان
المشكله هي الانقلاب الامين العامه
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل يرفض تسميته
انقلاب ولكنه يقول اليوم ان الاتحاد سيخوض
معركه لانقاذ تونس كيف فهمتم في المعارضه
هذا الكلام اين انتم من هذه المعركه
هو الكلاب بحكم المحكمه الافريقيه انا لا
اقول انه انقلاب
بمزاجي الخاص او بنتباع الخاص هو انقلاب
بحكم المحكمه الافريقيه وهو انقلاب بقرار
لجنه البندقيه للقوانين الدستوريه وهو
انقلاب براي اغلب اساتذه القانون الدستوري
في تونس ولذلك يجب تسميه الاسماء
بمسمياتها بعد ذلك الحوار يمكن ان ندور
الزوايا ولكن يجب تسميه الاسماء بمسمياتها
والجميع الان والاغلبيه الساهقات اصبحت ان
لم تسميه انقلاب تصيفه بانه التعسف في
استعمال السلطه هذا من من دكاتره وعاشات
اذا كانوا مقربين من قيس همم السيد همم
اين انتم في المعارضه من هذه الدعوه
للاتحاد العام التونسي الشغل لانقاذ او او
حديثه عن معركه لانقاذ تون يخوضها الاتحاد
المنظمات نحن كقوه سياسيه مسؤولين بدرجه
اولى على الموضوع السياسي في البلاد
اا نشجع ايا كان يريد ان يواجه هذا
الانقلاب لكن نرفض ما يتسرب من هنا وهناك
محاوله ايجاد حل باستبعاد الاحزاب التي هي
دعوه خارجيه هناك اطراف خارجيه او تراف
خارجي يريد ان يستبعد الاحزاب من تونس في
اي مبادره ولا يجب الخضوع لهذا والركوع
لهذه لانهم يريدون ان ينصبوا حكومه شكرا
في تونس لمده انتقاليه طويله يتم من
خلالها تاثير في الوضع في بلادنا بخيارات
لا وطنيه ولا شعبيه
في جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه ومحمد ذويب
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شكرا لكما ضيفنا
من تونس الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]